chances are you and your friends and
probably all your friends friends picked
up fallout 4 instead of Tomb Raider last
month even though Laura Crofts latest
adventure may not have sold as well as
many had hoped Microsoft is still
pleased with its success aaron greenberg
marketing executive at microsoft said
it's done well having launched in a
crowded market not to mention that it
came out the same day as one of the most
anticipated games of the year in an
interview with dualshockers Greenberg
noted that many people have held off on
buying Tomb Raider to play fallout but
he went on to say that he expects Tomb
Raider to continue to sell throughout
the holidays I know even over black
friday it did very well we've heard some
very nice feedback from some of our top
retailers so we'll continue to watch how
it performs but the game has definitely
been delivering for us Greenberg added
that Microsoft and Square Enix are also
pleased with rise of the tomb Raider's
critical response there are no official
numbers on rise of the Tomb Raider sales
but we'll be sure to let you know if we
find out more rise of the Tomb Raider is
now available for xbox one and it is
coming to PlayStation 4 in PC in 2016